so over the last few days i've been up
and down the country
mostly in the north of the country
buying houses
overseeing refurbs doing investment
hunting
development leeds liverpool manchester
and
amelia who's out filming with me uh what
did you ask me was the question that you
asked me
i just feel like we keep seeing like
really inexpensive houses
but i'm like how do you know that the
area because i said that you didn't know
i said about
you i said to you this area where we're
doing a deal i said
it's not in a grey area this is a pretty
bad area but it's not in a really bad
area
that's what i said right yeah and you
said what's the difference between a bad
area in a really bad area
and this is really important we're i
said right now i'm just driving
you to a really bad area we're going to
be there in a minute
a bad area is an area where you won't
particularly want to live but if your
mom lived there
you'll be like really but you won't be
like no
okay so you know it's okay you can get
decent tenants
where i'm taking you right now in fact
we're just approaching the road
it can't be either it the kind of can't
be
about to get to where if your mom lived
there
you'd be like you'd be like mom i'm
paying
for you to live somewhere else this is
uh one of the most infamous streets
in in the uk this is shield road you can
see
sofas outside the house broken glass on
the floor
this is the kind of but i feel like you
get that area it's very fire
everywhere like wet sofas outside the
they doing house my yeah red lights
oh man you can just tell that they're
dealing drugs
i mean amelia come on how would you feel
if your mom lived here well the fact
that there's people waiting on the
corner
oh my goodness look at those guys those
guys are dropping drugs out
for rabbi oh my gosh i don't feel so
good at the car right now
is filming oh my goodness look at this
all this run down stuff
cozy rooms so tonight you see that cozy
rooms place
that is your hotel that is your hotel
and you get all the drugs you want
so listen guys serious point now when
you're buying a property investment
go there at night make sure that
at night it feels safe if it doesn't
feel safe
and if there's literally ladies standing
on the side of the road and if you can
see people
dealing drugs broken glass surfaces
outside boarded up windows everywhere
that is not a good investment area
you're going to attract
the com no one will want to live there
you're only going to get
people on benefits you're going to get
crime you're going to get people not
paying their rent you're going to have
trash properties
so it's a balancing act if you buy a
property in an area that's a little bit
rough
like if a one if this is a one out of
ten as in like horrible
and a 10 out of 10 is like buckingham
palace
really and a five is just average
a three's okay now three is good you
don't want to be going for a ten
because the return investment is
terrible three's okay two's not cool
a one run a mile